今日は1年間お米券知っています初めて超
ですお米掲示してぼく何食べるようになっ
たと思いますからそーねえパンももちろん
食べますけどどちらかと言うと面で面での
方がハンガーに食べる量が増えましたこれ
ラーメンでもよく食べるしスティングを
よくしますねぱスティングはパッティング
かラーメンでかどっちかみたいなもう面で
面倒面で路面での成果とずっと知るわけな
んですけどもその目遠恋の中でも目指して
特に何が好きかと言われるとまつがいなく
こうございますあぶなー
クルースペスティーズワールドインチ
チャンピオン c ジャパン2020
多分はい千葉甘くないですか孟母パスタが
並んでたら祭なくカルボナーラ最初に取る
行ったミートソース仕掛けにそう
春コーナーに撮るんですよ間違いなくそれ
回もカルボナーないが膨らんでてちょっと
誰に電話で聞いてみるしかルボナーがとう
ございますからも女子
タッチ俺さぁ faster
コミュニティ買うとされても何頼んん
カルボナーうわーほんとにパスタの中でも
カルボナーが一番好きないけないという
わけで今日は有名なコンビの彼もなら集め
てみましたまずはこちらせるを入れるん
ですねセブンイレブンのカルボナーラば
冷凍食品でしたシンプルな名前ですね
スパゲッティカルボナーラカロリーが
419キロカロリー見た目も結構シンプル
っぽいですね付いてロードですこれはもう
をリアルに60回食べた方がいますチーズ
チーズ彼もとってもチーズ味あふれるカル
ボナーふんだんにチーズがかけられており
ますねかなり籠136kcal
めちゃめちゃに美味しいです卵がジュ
ワーって広がってこのチーズの間行って
食べた瞬間も続いてファミリーマーですお
かあさん食堂っていうお惣菜コーナーが
あるんですけどもそこの北海のさん生
クリームと2種チーズのカルボナーラパラ
眉山シェアしようカロリー輸液を出っ
キロカロリー年かファミリーマートは昔
このタイプの売ってたんですよ田中する奴
片っ端からお店に問い合わせてもどこも
売ってなくてやっちゅう製本て来ない
らしいってていいさんから投げてみました
なのでこちらはちょっと冷凍といいますか
このタイプのやつになっておりますついて
ミニストップさんの生パスタカルボナーラ
とトップバリュさんの役ですねさあこの
妖精のカルボナーラ混ぜて食べればマン
違いないと美味しい事いいと限りなしっ
あの僕結構うるさいんですよ僕結構
カルボナーラに感謝まずしたい超えてると
思っておりまして全部混ぜるに当たっても
不安要素はもあるんですよ僕止まってない
ですかいつもあったら言っておいで他の人
にあるんですけどもうあの時分から不安
要素を上げていくというこの姿勢本気で
かるぼなーと今向かい合っております外れ
社長です気になるポイントですね麺の太さ
がバラバラなんですねミニストップの
ローソンのパスはフィトッチーね方といい
ますか薄い長いタイプなんですけどもそれ
に立って7とファミリーマートはまっすぐ
なよくあるパターンの形なのでそこの麺の
組み合わせが果たしてどう響いてくるのか
チョコが非常にポイントですがまぁ前の
混ぜる前にちょっとこう食べながら塗って
いきたいと思いますでは行こう
バッハ
4位
じゃああのはカンナカーアーマーにゃーん
あっはっtanよしあのじゃあ上の冠
コーナーが6分だったら持ってきて染めの
ヤッホー言え th チッチッっをできた
があ
いつも怖い怖い怖いかこ怖い怖い出っ張っ
たが待った甲斐ねっちゃー
はいじゃあはいイターあったかいい
社長らよ
rまあまあ ok で少しこれもらって2
分半
このなく日本まだまだた
ドンッ
ぜひたやつから見ていきましょうかまずは
7のカルボナーラです
うわぁ数まっそうだが私は不味いわけが
ないでしょうみたいな見た目をしており
ますいただきます
俺とんてきに他のカルボナーラだからさあ
何食っても美味しいと言いそうなんだよな
越中水ファミリーマートいきましょう
お母さん尺度ちょっと卵に靴良いですかね
見た目もう7ノット違いが分かりません
いただきます
hey
なるほどね微妙に7と味の違いは感じます
が全然美味しいで続いてローンの膣から
もうこれは食わなくてもれ味分かりますで
はローソンいただきますいやもう何か労組
はトロトロな印象がセグっている一緒に卵
で
であります
うんも慣れ親しんだぜの所為かも知れませ
んがめっちゃくちゃ美味しいです
ありがとうございますでは最後にミニ
ストップのパパですこれはもう食べたこと
ないですねなんか余計のめっちゃ入ってん
なーなんか臭いってるし
草津ライン口だけはないさちょうだい
軌道ですか
ごはんですね大ます
あ馬いるは名がとっても柔らかいし
クリーミーいやこれカルボナーラ全部
美味しいということで4店舗のパスター
その通りなんですけども掘り多いんだから
一つに混ぜていきたいとおもいます御来光
はあああああ
ああああああ
シャヒン
うわああっ
すーっ
[音楽]
voodoo
きてきてきてきてきた後も装ってくるわけ
ですここまでもしっかり前させていただき
ましょうじゃあなんか思っていい感じなら
多分これいろんな面が勝ってるんでまず
おいしそうな気がすんだよ
えっ
ページが入ってますね
どうやって完成いたしましたみなさんは
どちらがジョン店舗のコンビニが力を作っ
立つめちゃスペシャルからぼーだーらーざ
ザベスっ
いいえ
[音楽]
カルボナーラってこういうオシャレに置く
ことに意味のあるキャラ気がするんですよ
ね
いや舌ようになった孫の香りがします
いろんな面がしっかり重なって身近するの
で味的には全くおいしそうな気はするいや
俺ほんとカルボナーラに感謝まずで売る
たいんでちょっと緊張しておりますが
しっかりと感想は言わせていただきますで
あります
のん
全部一緒
[音楽]
elena ピョン指示普通に美味しいで
もなんかさあ春のなぁラガー
美味しいだけなんですね混ぜたところで
美味しいものが美味しかったです
[音楽]
ねんですねぇー
voodoo
みんなーーーん